Here I've drawn a problem which is a classic 2-dimensional motion problem.
Before we get into it, though, let's remind ourselves about the equations we learned in 1-dimensional motion.
These equations relate a few variables--Δx, initial velocity,  time, acceleration, and velocity,
which we called some final velocity.
I'm going to write those over here.
To fully understand an object's motion in one dimension,
we like to somehow decide what the values were for all of these variables.
In 2-dimensional motion, I said we're just solving two of these 1-dimensional problems.
So, we need to make some copies.
Δx is going to partner with Δy.
V₀--ah, wait. V₀ I'm going to call V₀ₓ, like I did over here.
To distinguish between whether the velocity is horizontal or vertical,
its partner will be V₀ᵧ.
There's going to be two accelerations--one in the x direction and one in the y.
Likewise, two final velocities.
Interestingly enough, however, there's only going to be one time.
There's no x and y version of time, because unlike position, velocity, and acceleration,
there's no easy way to assign a direction to time.
In physics, we call time a scalar, and these other quantities are vectors.
You don't have to worry about the vocabulary for now.
If we want to know the trajectory of this ball as it travels through the air,
our goal is to get numerical answers for each of these quantities.
Some we can already fill in. V₀ₓ I know will be 10 m/s.
This is the number that I just gave you at the start of the problem.
What about Δy? Can you tell me what Δy will be in meters?